today is not a celebration it's a deep
sigh of relief we have lost so many of
our heroes and sadly more will continue
to get sick and more will die and today
is not about the politicians who are
here to serve the public we work for the
people here standing with us and those
who couldn't be here today it's all
about them their families their selfless
service and that they answered the call
of duty when our nation asked it's about
the people standing behind me who have
been here for weeks and months and years
over and over and over again coming back
here where they never should have had to
do that so before I answer these so
before I introduce our speakers I just
want to thank so many of the people who
worked so hard to make this bill
permanent Jon Stewart and John feel
International Association of
firefighters and especially the New York
City uniformed firefighters and fire
officers Police Benevolent Association
sergeants benevolent association federal
law Enforcement Officers Association
National Association of police
organization Port Authority PBA New York
State afl-cio dc37 American Federation
of State County and Municipal Employees
New York City Building Trades United
Federation of Teachers Operating
Engineers laborers citizens for
extension of the James Zadroga Act
plumbers and by name Ben Shabbat Suzy
Valentine Chris Graham Burke Andy
Edmiston Shannon Meisner Pegg seminar EO
dr. James melius a memorandum Emery and
the entire feel good foundation team
rich Palmer Matt McCauley Mike O'Connell
Kenny SPECT Keith Delmer Keith Delmar
Kenny Saylor's and marine Fitz
a Yvonne Sanchez Joe McKay Mike Clancy
Dave Turner Troy Hutchinson Brendan
Fitzpatrick ray sikozu Kowski Rafael
Orosco Phil Alvarez David Alvarez
Fernando Alvarez Tom Wilson Bryen
McGuire mark Mack Tyson Jones Phil Rizzo
Karen Pfeiffer eight oligo al Williams
rich trial Donnell Holbrook Kevin swag
bomb Elias whose mama Dean Robert Arash
Michael Michael bearish Brigitte Bromley
Lila Nordstrom Lee London Sean Riordan
Frank
Chacho Rob Sarah Brian finally Jerry
severs and Margaret Alvarez I now like
to introduce Senator Chuck Schumer and I
can tell you you've never had a fighter
like Senator Schumer on your side
someone who's never given up who's never
given in who's made sure he stood by for
every single time this bill passed Sara
Schumer Thank You senator Gillibrand and
let me thank you for the amazing job you
have done she worked the floor endlessly
getting names that we never thought like
cotton and Cruz who could be on this
bill and the proof of the pudding the
great job she did and all the people
behind me did is set in two numbers 97
and to 97 and to righteousness sometimes
sometimes in this mangled town sometimes
prevails and thank God today it did I
want to thank all the people of Kirsten
thanked most of all all the folks behind
us now they can do what they want to do
they never wanted to come here they
would have rather been with their
families with their brothers and sisters
who they knew were ill with their
friends ministering caring as our first
responders are trained to do and I've
always done not just
9:11 but on every day and now they can
go back and do what they really wanted
to do they didn't want to be here they
didn't like being here but they had a
sense of duty and nevertheless they
persisted and we've achieved this goal
I'd like to say particularly we have
great 21st century heroes whose names
are a droga and Pfeiffer and Alvarez and
I'd say to the Zadroga and Pfeiffer and
Alvarez families many of whom are here
your losses painful as they are are not
in vain as today shows the men you lost
and all the others did what the Bible
says we should all do not curse the
darkness but light a candle and today
that candle burns very very brightly so
to all of our friends who made this
happen for all of us who now breathe one
gigantic sigh of relief particularly the
men and women behind me thank you
this is tough times for America
sometimes we doubt its goodness and it's
awfully hard to have that good shine
through but today it did thank God it
did let it be a beacon to everyone else
I put on this flag nine twelve or one I
wear it every day it represented close
to 3,000 people who were lost and
unfortunately every day this flag
represents more people but we'll never
take it off as long as there are brave
people who stood up for us and this flag
and all flags will remind us that we
have to stand up for them who's next
our next speaker is Senator Cory Gardner
who had the courage and bravery to lead
the fight on behalf of the Republicans
in our chamber quick runner Thank You
senator Gillibrand for your incredible
leadership on this on September 11th and
days following we all remember
but our country was going through the
flags that were waving and draped across
bridges people standing on street
corners rallying to their nation's cause
the men and women standing in this group
today didn't hesitate to take that call
I can't put into words the people that I
have met with here or a home who did so
much for this country not knowing that
it could cost them their life for a
loved one's life not knowing they would
ever doubt Congress and the resolve of
this place to do what is right but out
of the ashes and debris of September
11th arose hope and courage and strength
and commitment and those acts resulted
in a vote today of 97 to - I won't
forget we won't forget and today you
know all of it that this country stands
with you and for you thank you for your
work you resolve your sacrifice your
commitment and courage because when this
country is called upon again we can all
say please stand up because we have
proven that we will stand up for you
Thanks what you've done our next two
speakers are John feel 9/11 first
responder in 911 health advocate and
John Stewart
like together
you know uh Mitch McConnell said
politics is a contact sport these people
leave the lumba they they tackle the
Congress and then the Senate and I can't
be more proud of them
you know when I was here a couple weeks
ago we passed a bill in the house I said
this was no longer about legislation we
knew we were gonna get the bill passed
this is about the bond and the
friendship of those on the hill those in
the media and those who I walk the halls
of Congress with passing this
legislation there's no joy there's no
comfort yes I cried with John but that
was to exhale that was to get 18 years
of pain and suffering out and I believe
it's out I'm gonna ask my team now to
put down your swords and pick up your
rapes and go home and hopefully we don't
have to come back when I'm going to miss
the most about DC is nothing and no
offense to Chuck and Kirsten and Carolyn
and Peter who and I'm not being biased
there dad better people than they are
elected officials and they're pretty
good elected officials and I and I mean
that sincerely and you know to Mitch
McConnell he kept his word to me
he kept his word to those men that were
in the meeting with me and my while I
don't always agree with his politics he
was honest he was sincere and everything
he said he did so I think Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell that's
for Rand Paul and Mike Lee told you so
we whipped your asses 97 to 297 when one
does the Senate ever get that I mean I'm
just so proud of these guys behind women
behind me what Dave accomplished and
what they sacrificed that they drove
down 95 countless time stopping and
restaurant was taking medications having
their wives and yelling at me make sure
my husband takes his medication
watching them throw up watching them
shake watching them cry their toll on
these guys physically and mentally I
don't know how much longer they would
have made it but I know we would not
have made it to December where we would
have got attached to a larger vehicle in
2010 we got unanimous consent the 2015
we got attached to a larger vehicle we
saw an opportunity we had a small window
and we took advantage of it and we're
leaving DC on our terms and we're going
out with dignity and class we got our
straight up-and-down vote 97 to 2 that
is the most amazing thing I've ever seen
and I'll leave you with this in the
beginning of change the Patriot is a
scarce man brave hated and scorned when
his cost exceeds the Timmy join him for
then of course nothing to be a patriot
Mark Twain
our next speaker is John Stewart and I
have to say this is a man who didn't
have to do what he did he spent all the
capital he had gained over a lifetime of
success and he spent it helping the
people here yes I think we can all agree
on the real hero hard not to see it that
way
there's been the honor of my life to
work with the men and women behind me
today it's about the heart James who
drove good and Joe in the integrity of a
fight first and the courage of Lu
Alvarez and the tenacity of John feel
they they lifted this 9/11 community on
their shoulders and they carried them
home and I will always be so proud to
have been associated with it and we can
never repay all that the 9/11 community
has done for our country but we can stop
penalizing them and today is that day
that they can excel because
unfortunately the the pain and suffering
of what these heroes continue to go
through is going to continue there have
been too many funerals too many hospices
these families deserve better and I'm
really I'm hopeful that today
begins the process of being able to heal
without the burden of having to advocate
and I will follow you whatever your next
adventure shall be our next speaker is
congresswoman carolyn Maloney who what
has worked this bill for almost twenty
years and she has worked from the very
beginning as the first person to
introduce it and someone who never gave
up first of all I want to recognize and
thank the first responders and the
survivors and their families for their
selfless and tireless work on this bill
and thank you to my colleagues in the
house the speaker Pelosi leader Hoyer
and and my very good friend congressman
Nadler and King for their leadership
Nadler cannot be with us he gives his
warmest regards and they led us to 402
to 12 in the house I think it's the most
strongest bipartisan vote building on
that is this vote today in the Senate I
I thank our advocates of John field Jon
Stewart and really the the real Twin
Towers of New York the inspiration to me
throughout this bill their work on that
day the police and fire New York Fire
Department York Police Department for
what they do for us every day and today
of the extraordinary leadership of
senators Gillibrand Schumer and Gardner
were evidenced with this very strong
vote where we passed the never forget
the heroes James Zadroga ray Pfeiffer
and Luis Alvarez permanent authorization
of the September 11 Victims Compensation
Fund Act that's the title of the bill
and it would not have happened without
all the people standing here today labor
advocates families everyone it has been
an
honor to stand beside you in this flight
I just wish it hadn't taken so long and
that we hadn't lost so many friends
along the way including the 18 we've
lost in the past two weeks since louis
alvarez died
this woman is for James Zadroga Rae
fight for Louis Alvarez and what they
stand for and all of the others who have
gotten sick or passed away because of
their time spent at Ground Zero the
Pentagon and the Shanksville crash site
the vote today is a win for our country
and the heroes and survivors who were
there for us the 9/11 community now
knows that they and their families have
the measure of security that comes with
the permanent funding of the Victims
Compensation Fund permanently for their
lives we we have a moral obligation to
take care of the people who took care of
us and those who take care of them
first and foremost for what they did on
9/11 in the days and weeks and months
that passed afterwards but secondly
because of the toxic lie that our
government told them that it was safe to
work on the pile when it was not we want
to underscore and be clear that 9/11 was
an attack on our nation not just on New
York and the people who need and deserve
this program live in all 50 states and
in 433 out of the 435 congressional
districts if you remember 9/11 you
remember that we as a nation vowed to
never forget today the Senate kept that
promise today we did the right thing for
the right reason for the right people
today is a day of which all Americans
can be proud
god bless our heroes in our nation and
thank you
[Applause]
all right our net speaker I would wear
the coat till we pass the bill well done
[Applause]
our next speaker is Jose the troca the
father of NYPD detective James Zadroga
was the first to die because of a 911
illness today is a great day let me tell
you it started for this a droga family
December 2001 he came home sick we went
to the hospital we went to Columbia
Presbyterian
that's pulmonologist in his state and
you know what he told us I'm not gonna
treat it and that went on for five years
trying to get him help try to get him
treatment went the hospital torn out of
hospital at the hospital spoke to news
TV stations nobody wanted the story
nobody wanted to talk about it took his
death for it to come to light that
people were sick and only then did the
TV channels come down news channels come
down and took up the story if it wasn't
for that medical examiner in New Jersey
who had the guts to come out and say he
died from 9/11 who knows how much longer
it would have been before the governor
came to realize not realized meant that
people were dying from 9/11 illnesses
I'm gonna thank a lot of people here I
know I'm gonna forget a lot of people
but we have to mention the people that
were there from the start I I I was
asked to speak in front of a
congressional hearing and Senator
Hillary Clinton was there she took up
the fight she was the first one to take
up the fight for the responders she got
built yes
for the police and the fire and later on
for all responders congresswoman Maloney
was right there with her I will never
forget her I never forget a week and
Senator Gillibrand picked up the fight
when Hillary moved on to other things
first time on TV
Neil Caputo 20 seconds on TV speaking
about 911 about the bull dying I said in
the end I said 20 seconds this is after
this game don't worry kid
this is going to go this is going to go
past didn't know what TV recognition did
but we moved on I'd like to thank the
North the NYPD they were great taking
care of Tyler in after her father died
one thing they do they take care of
their office we had it for 17 years 17
years old now I'm so proud of her
I'm proud that we're here today and we
got this bill passed I'm proud that the
Jimmy's name is on there I'm proud that
he's like got two other heroes on there
with them God knows that they belong
there and god bless them god bless our
families a couple I told the families of
9/11 in front I just wanted think he's
not here today and then even know I'm TJ
it was my sidekick he was on that kicked
me in the ass when I was down he told me
we gotta go out there and get things
done he was the one I remember how to
get around this place I never would
always been lost at the time so you know
I thanked him and of course my wife you
know she was there for me I was here for
her if it wasn't for her I don't know if
I could have survived all these years
but again it wasn't for God I don't know
if I would survive but again I like it
on the high notes
thank God it's done it's passed and
hopefully God we never have to come back
here again for this reason
all I want to come back boys you take
Polly Raylan I got it thank you
[Applause]
our next speaker is Karin Pfeiffer she's
the wife of New York City firefighter
ray Pfeiffer
it was lost earlier this year good
afternoon
unfortunately my speech I was told
what's the possibly before the vote so
I'll play around anyway my name is Karen
Pfeiffer
my husband was FDNY firefighter ray
Pfeifer Ray responded to the New York
City World Trade Center 9/11 attacks
that day he lost many of his dear
friends and his fellow firefighters we
continue to respond to Ground Zero over
the many weeks and months on a recovery
mission to bring back the remains of his
fallen brothers all the while he was a
voice for all first responders who were
suffering from illnesses they contracted
as a result of their rescue and recovery
efforts at Grant Ground Zero I am here
to be raised voice Ray was part of this
team to feel good foundation team they
were working to get the passage of
health care bills over the years getting
the support they needed Ray's passion
was to help Wallas brothers and sisters
dying from 9/11 illnesses and Ray came
down here many times with the team in
his wheelchair up and down the halls and
doing the best he could unfortunately
Ray was diagnosed in 2009 with stage
four cancer which started with the pain
in his hips Ray was a husband a father
and a firefighter which he lived for
where he will never see his children
married or meet his grandchildren
they passed away May 28th 2017 we
watched race suffer in pain for seven
years with eleven surgeries these team
members have traveled down here numerous
times walking the halls and advocating
for our heroes they all deserve our
thanks their hard work for the
responders have had paid off and I just
want to thank the dissenter in the
Congress for Ray's name I was so honored
to have Ray's name on the legislation I
mean it was so proud and I know Ray's
looking down today and just saying god
bless you all and it's finally done we
could all be at peace now we don't have
to worry our families will be okay and
then let these heroes rest in peace and
and I mean I'm exhausted
[Applause]
our next speaker is congresswoman excuse
me our next speaker is Congressman Peter
King and I just want to thank Peter for
leading the charge from the Republican
side from the beginning of this advocacy
thank you for your leadership and
strength Thank You Kirsten only just at
the outset thank kissing Dover and
Senator Schumer Chuck Schumer at Senate
Cory Gardner who was a great voice in
the Senate on the Republican side I want
to thank him for was bipartisan efforts
in the house of Koster nate'll and Carol
Maloney I want to again they've been
there from the start I want to commend
them for it NYPD Port Authority police
FDNY destruction unions labor unions
some of the advocates citizens from the
gia neighborhood this was a tremendous
victory today but it's bittersweet
because we know and so in celebrating is
want to call that a victory we also
remember those who died those who were
sick today those become sick in the
future so this is again it's a great
achievement it shows that Congress can
get things done but really it's a
lasting testament and memorial to the
men and women behind us those with their
lives in the line goes who risked their
lives and again the incredible coverage
that was shown talking about droga
you're talking about the Alvarez family
you're talking about the Fife and family
to see the wild rose here just a few
months ago and the actually reasonably
healthy back in February than to see him
the way he was just several months after
that raid Pfeiffer kept seeing him over
the years and years and some of the
events in Long Island New York and down
here Congress again these guys have
incredible guts and stamina and their
families stood with them so we have to
commend all of them and the end it was
really an honor for me to be part of
this to work with these great men and
women who because of them we will never
ever forget the memory of 9/11 the
heroism of 9/11 and today's vote is just
a tremendous but again to me a
tremendous tribute to the men and women
the senator garden John anyway with the
house who got it done and again I can't
read about Jon Stewart what he did that
day you know this probably would have
asked
I'm along the line but after that date
run scared the hell out of everybody
what'd he want
and yeah don't nobody have the nerve to
say no and again you see majubi nice
guys well-spoken guy easygoing guy and
you get him on the cause get out of his
way and also drunk field again great
work all of you but let's never forget
the people are still suffering and will
suffer the future thank you very much
[Applause]
yes I also want to thank the New York
City correction officers who are here
and the pit bulls were working
correction and stalwart support for this
cause thank you for all you've done to
walk the halls with us our next speaker
is David Alvarez the son of NYPD
detective Louis thank you everyone did
not know I was gonna be speaking but I
just want to say when my father
testified not too long ago he said that
he was coming down here to make sure
that you never forget and I want to
thank you for not forgetting him not
forgetting all the other first
responders who tirelessly worked to see
this pass so thank you
[Applause]
our next speaker is Harold shite Berger
president International Association of
firefighters and I just want to take the
opportunity on behalf of three hundred
and sixteen thousand members that's all
right you know give them a break it's a
little warm in here right keep going
that's right
but on behalf of our entire membership
three hundred sixteen thousand of the
very best our leadership in New York USA
president gerard Fitzgerald and his team
are UF o-- you a president Jake l'amanda
and his team our international union and
part of our leadership ed Kelly our
general secretary treasurer and to
everybody here a leader Schumer and sit
senator Gillibrand
congresswoman Maloney and Congressman
King and so many to list but say thank
you this has been an extraordinary
journey and I've watched extraordinary
work and I've watched Jon feel and they
feel good foundation and admired their
work and I watched Jon Stewart actually
bring a bright light on this issue to
make sure a nation knew what needed to
be done and what was a difficult journey
and the fact is I'm so thankful to so
many just on behalf of our members not
those that have been lost that will
always be the legacy for all of us but
for those that are going to now have the
comfort and the confident to know
they'll have a care and the health
benefits and the compensation to be able
to have some peace and not have to worry
maybe day by day or year by year whether
or not they're going to be cut off from
the support that they have earned you
know almost eighteen years ago this
nation was attacked and starting on that
day and all the days and weeks and
months that followed
we're proud of our own but it was
workers across all the sectors it served
it was in a recovery and rescue and then
cleanup stages that everyone from the
trades and the electrician's everyone
who was at Ground Zero and sacrificed
their own health to serve a nation and
the last thing I'm thankful for having
been at this for a long long time mr.
leader as you know is that I'm thankful
that we won't have to come back to this
podium on this issue again that our
Congress and our Senate its leadership
has shown America that the process can
work and that you can advance important
issues and legislation and now this
measure is put to bed in law that will
take care of those quite frankly
forevermore thank you so much for
everything everybody good our next
speaker is Pat Lynch the president of
the Police Benevolent Association of the
city of New York
his there's so many to say thank you to
our senators our Congress folks there's
so many folks that fought for us there's
so many folks behind us that we're at
Ground Zero all aspects when it was the
towers when it was the pile when it was
the pit all of it toxic I thank them for
allowing guys like us folks like us
Americans to try to live free because
they rushed on in but more importantly
we want to thank all families
we choose it our families don't but they
stand with us anyway
sometimes they're standing on a stoop
waiting for us to come home for those
families who watch the suffering and
lost their loved ones I thank you for
those that are home now that are sick
this doesn't fix everything it just
eases the pain I thank those that are
struggling to breathe on their couch
I thank their family members who are
doing everything they can to try to help
them you know ninety seven to to a lot
of folks focus on the ninety seven I'm
sorry I focus on the two I can't help it
it's what we do you know I heard speech
upstairs that said you know why are we
rushing 18 years that's some rush but
you know the reality is the reality is
some of us are in a rush some of us in a
rush because they need this imagine the
police so offices the firefighters and
correctional officers and those that
have died since then died working folks
that we go to work to provide for our
family that died thinking that family
won't be provided for you know so yes
some of us in a rush some of his in a
rush to leave here today to go back to
the city to go back to Staten Island to
go to the wake the detective Chris
Cranston whose family were correction
officers whose family were police
officers who family all at him on the
pile well we're going to a funeral home
so you know whatever I do these a day
like today I'm I'm happy but I'm sad I'm
be it's done but I'm sad because we have
to deliver news I'm happy because
finally the fights over but then I'm sad
because I realize it's really not so
we're gonna go here we're gonna bow our
heads we're gonna go over that wake when
they try to give that family some solace
but remember those two remember Chris
Cranston stopped breathing worrying that
he couldn't provide for his family I
want to also recognize those who served
at the Pentagon members of our FBI
members members of our other first
responders many of are here today and I
just want to thank you all for your
service I am now going to introduce Paul
Nancy Otto the president of the Port
Authority Police Benevolent Association
[Applause]
good afternoon
thankfully for me I was only asked to
speak this morning while I was on the
train down emotions for every first
responder behind me are right back to
911 I didn't want to fumble my words so
I wrote them down good afternoon
the bill not only represents the
sacrifices at 37 Port Authority police
officers 23 New York City police
officers and 343 New York City
firefighters but the countless first
responders that came running to Ground
Zero to assist with the rescue recovery
efforts as all of you are aware first
responders came from all departments
across our country this is also about
Patriots patriotism by our iron workers
Operating Engineers the building trades
doctors nurses and countless others that
ran to help us this is about ordinary
citizens that went to work and we're the
victims of the worst attack on American
soil since Pearl Harbor this is about
every citizen who was affected by the
attacks every family member that lost
and continued to loss lose loved ones
myself in life
respondent came running when you needed
us and now 18 years later you're
honoring your commitment to never forget
for our brothers and sisters that are
sick and dying we will never forget your
commitment in sacrifice or your families
I would like to thank Senator Gillibrand
senator schumer congressman king along
with all the members of the Senate in
Congress who honored their commitment to
never forget us and to John still I love
you thank you sir our next speaker is
Jake l'amanda president uniform Fire
Association fire Officers Association
local eight five four i AFF afl-cio and
jela Fitzgerald president uniformed
Firefighters Association local 94 IAF F
afl-cio good afternoon
on behalf of New York City Fire offices
both active and retie I'm here to say
thanks I'll keep my comments brief but I
would have to say thank you to New York
delegation both in the house and in the
Senate because they stood there with us
from day one right through this plate
it's been a long journey I won't fight
it was a fight with many faces but in
the end we came together as a voice of
one and out of that dust out of those
ashes Rose the words never forget never
forget I'm here to tell you that from
coast to coast America did not forget
and what we witnessed in the house and
today in the Senate our elected
officials they stood by those words and
they finally never forgot us thank you
our next speaker is Mario salento our
president of the New York State Oh Jill
senator Schumer's making fun of my
Brooklyn accent already the do's and the
don Zoey I'm sure I Fitzgerald president
UFA I'm gonna keep my comments brief
also I want to thank the New York
delegation this would never have gotten
done they've been fighting for this for
a long time I think person as long as
you've been on your the newbie but we're
very proud of the New York delegation
and how they got bipartisan politics but
the vote today I'm not gonna call it
bipartisan politics I'm gonna call it
that it was bipartisan humanity and
twelve people from the house and two
from the Senate proof that they don't
have enough humanity to have voted this
into legislation so I'm proud that it's
got done I guess I'm happy the only
problem is is that somebody has to get
sick or die to collect this money so
there's not a lot of celebrating on this
it's important that every call every
time that somebody is in that position
they always say all I'm worried about is
my family will they be taking care of I
know they the police the fire department
we take care of our own I'm sure
everybody is in that but those are the
two that I'm familiar with I think that
will continue but having this money
there will help as they as they are
getting ready to meet their maker and
it's important so thank you very much
thank you to all the politicians across
the country that did the right thing
thank you
our next speaker is Mario salento our
president of New York State afl-cio we
want to get in front of a senator thank
you
Thank You senator tonight and again I
want to thank all of the elected
officials who are here today thank you
for your dedication and your commitment
and really your your your perseverance
for all these years uh let me just say
this on behalf of the two and a half
million members of the New York State
afl-cio I want to thank everyone here I
want to take a moment to thank the labor
leaders who are here jake'll Amanda and
Jerrod Fitzgerald Matt Lynch and and of
course Herald shaped burger and I want
to thank them because you set a standard
for all labor leaders throughout this
country the passion you have you've had
for the past 18 years to fight for what
you fight make us all better throughout
the labor movement I thank you all for
that as for mr. Jon Stewart Jon I don't
know you we don't know each other but I
do know that you learn a lot about
someone when they fight for other people
when they don't have to it shows
everything about their their character
and their integrity and Thank You Jon
and Jon feel goes without saying thank
you let me just say this you know I'm
proud having worked at the State afl-cio
for over 27 years to say this that
eighteen years ago the labor movement
made a promise throughout the state
public sector unions and private sector
unions and building trade unions from
Buffalo to Brooklyn to Long Island and
everywhere in between that we would
stand side by side and shoulder to
shoulder with our brothers and sisters
who led this fight to be there to
support them to be there for whatever it
was that they need and and today we kept
our promise to all of them and we keep
in mind one last thing is that you know
in the late movement we consider
ourselves a family we call each other
brothers and sisters for a reason but we
also know intuitively that we don't have
to be blood-related to be a family and
we don't have to look alike or talk
alike or sound alike to be a family a
family is a group of people who join
together for a lot of different reasons
who care about one another who help one
another who support one another and who
pick each other up when one of us falls
down and if you pick on one of us you
have to deal with all of us that's a
family and today we showed what a true
family is we show the family
the labor movement we also also showed
that we can be a family of citizens as
Americans and as human beings and I
think that's why today 6x all day and
why we're all thankful to be here thank
you very much our last speaker is Lila
Nordstrom a student at Stuyvesant High
School during 9/11 my name is Lila um I
was a student at Stuyvesant High School
on 9/11 Stuyvesant is three blocks from
the World Trade Center and we were there
for about eight months of the cleanup
and I'm a little bit at loss for words
cuz I've never actually gotten to speak
at one of these things without having to
threaten to see everyone back here in
five years this has been sort of the
work of my entire adult life at this
point I'm 35 I made my first trip down
here at 22 and every five years I've
sort of I've been coming back and
telling the same story and trying to
convince the same people that the same
issues still matter and so it's a huge
relief that I don't have to make that
threat this time a huge amount of thanks
is obviously owed to our wonderful New
York delegation to carolyn maloney and
peter king for ushering this through to
Jerry Nadler for making sure that the
survivor community was included in this
legislation for always making sure that
we were a part of the discussion and
then of course to our great New York
State Senators for assuring this through
the Senate and also to my classmates and
the many responders who live outside of
New York who made calls to their local
representatives and let them know that
this was a constituent issue for them as
well I've been living in California for
12 of the 13 years I've been doing this
a lot of my classmates live outside of
the city outside of New York State and
for all of us it was really important
that we see this kind of unity in the
vote because this really is a
constituent issue for every single
senator a lot of us who do this work
don't just do the work of educating you
guys about our exposures we also do the
considerably less glamorous work of
reaching out to our community and making
sure that they are
taking care of making sure that they are
aware these services are available to
them and able to take advantage of them
and having the danger of these programs
expiring every five years made that work
much more difficult so it's with huge
relief that we will be able to go back
home and engage in that less glamorous
but much more important work without our
communities worrying that they were
gonna be forgotten in a few years
without people worrying that if they
don't get sick by next year they have no
one you know no one will have their back
and as part of that work I have one
final message which is I know survivors
don't see ourselves reflected in
coverage of this issue very often so I
just want to reiterate that this program
is for us - it is for you if you are a
survivor if you are someone who like me
got sent in to lower Manhattan as a
child and spent eight months in a toxic
environment if you are somebody who had
you know who was encouraged by a by a
government lie that you know to go back
into your home and was not given proper
guidance about how to clean that up if
you returned to work and had smoke
blowing into your window for four months
and heard again and again that there you
know there was nothing to be afraid of
and only now or finding out that there
was something to be afraid of then you
have done your part to earn access to
these programs if I could cut out of my
life the amount of time that I spend
convincing six survivors that they are
worthy of these programs that it is ok
to apply to them that they should not
feel guilty about taking advantage of
these programs I could probably write a
novel or learn a new language or
something um but so as a final note I
just want to make sure that survivors
all over all over the nation realize
that these programs are for us - and I'm
thrilled that from now on we'll be able
to look forward instead of looking
backwards and trying to continually
revisit this part of the issue
there are ways in which the survivor
community will you know that there are
big implications for us in the larger
health care debate there are research
implications for us and we want to make
sure that we can talk about those issues
instead of just constantly revisiting
this one thank you so much
I just want to thank everyone who's here
today for coming for being part of this
effort and I just want to say thank you
one last time to the men and women
standing with us today thank you
[Applause]